l'allemagne satisfait au sujet de sa
situation sanitaire actuelle celle ci
semble s'améliorer selon les autorités
alors que le nombre de contaminés en
europe a presque doublé au cours des dix
derniers jours les allemands constate
chaque jour une baisse des nouvelles
personnes infectées
parmi les chiffres parlants celui du
taux d'infection un individu infecté
contamine désormais en moyenne moins
d'une personne autour de lui afin
d'anticiper la suite les pouvoirs
publics ont annoncé la fabrication de 50
millions de masques par semaine à
compter du mois d'août
plus de 4000 personnes sont décédées
dans le pays depuis le début de la crise
du coronavirus un bilan qui reste lourd
mais nettement inférieur aux autres
puissances européennes
une épidémie redevenu gérable selon le
ministre allemand de la santé nous
pouvons maintenant dire que cela
réussisse nous avons réussi à passer
d'une croissance dynamique à une
croissance linéaire les taux d'infection
diminué de manière significative en
particulier l'augmentation relative jour
après jour l'épidémie est redevenu
gérable et sous contrôle aujourd'hui je
trouve qu un chiffre très important et
encourageant est que depuis le 12 avril
le nombre de personnes qui se sont
rétablis chaque jour est supérieur au
nombre de personnes nouvellement
infectées
à l'heure actuelle nous avons plus de
80000 guérison sur les cent trente mille
personnes infectées jusqu'à présent
selon les chiffres de l'institut robert
koch
l'allemagne espère désormais ne pas
devoir faire face à une seconde vague
épidémique de cofidis